eine junge frau die chattet mit ihrer
besten freundin so weit so gut gibt
nichts auffälliges allerdings sagten sie
mal hier drauf im hintergrund da sehen
wir auch den mann der frau sie spricht
mit ihrer freundin über rezepte doch
heimlich gibt sie dann ihrer freundin
ein handzeichen in diesem chat hier
sehen wir es so dass ihr mann das nicht
sehen kann ein handzeichen das hilfe
heiß ich brauche hilfe signalisiert
diese frau mein mann ist nämlich
gewalttätig in deutschland spricht jetzt
über genau dieses handzeichen grund eine
brutale vergewaltigung auf einem
spielplatz in ludwigshafen und eben
genau dieses handzeichen
tatort spielplatz hier im rheinland
pfälzischen ludwigshafen ist das 14
jährige mädchen von ihrer vergewaltiger
in die büsche gezogen wurden dort wird
sie von dem 19-jährigen zu sexuellen
handlungen gezwungen gnadenlos macht
sich der täter über sein argloses opfer
her eine quälend lange zeit muss das
mädchen das mit theorien über sich
ergehen lassen bis eine passantin nach
dem mutigen mädchen gelingt es eine hand
frei zu bekommen und mit einer hand
geste auf sich aufmerksam zu machen mit
der so genannten signal vorhält geste
signalisiert die 14-jährige der
passantin dass sie dringend hilfe
braucht die trauer kennt die geste
reagiert sofort und alarmierte umgehend
die polizei die beamten neben den 19
jährigen fest der spielplatz
vergewaltiger ist der polizei bereits
einschlägig bekannt es wurde bereits
mehrfach vergeblich nach ihm gefahndet
in mindestens zwei weiteren fällen der
vorwurf vergewaltigung und sexuelle
nötigung in
offenburg soll der brutalem an
minderjährige mädchen mit nackt fotos
erpresst in mannheim wieder eine
minderjährige vergewaltigt haben und
trotzdem ist der gefährliche serientäter
auf freiem fuß hat hier die deutsche
justiz wieder einmal gepennt hätte ein
früheres eingreifen der behörden einem
unschuldigen 14 jährigen mädchen diese
grauenhaften erlebnisse womöglich
ersparen können
also schauen wir noch mal auf dieses
sehr wichtige handzeichen dass wir jetzt
alle kennen sollten es signalisiert
einen hilferuf und wirklich sie sollten
sich wirklich merken hier sehen wir auch
noch mal bilder von kindern die es auch
mittlerweile können ein zeichen das
zeigen soll dass man in not ist ohne
dass der täter ist vielleicht mitbekommt
[Musik]